not gonna lie it was weird this movie's
starting and there's no pixar short at
the beginning
it was part of the experience i didn't
see it anyway maybe they'll put it in
later i just
threw off my whole vibe
[Music]
soul so soul is the new pixar film the
biggest pixar film you will see on the
tv that's just the way it's going to be
for a while it's on disney plus stars
jamie foxx and tina fey jamie foxx plays
joe he loves jazz he wants to be a jazz
musician he's a middle school
band teacher at the moment but he has
this big opportunity and
he dies which got me off guard i didn't
know what the movie was about because
this is 2020 it's the year where
i don't have to see trailers because i
don't go to the movie theater so i'm
like if i don't have to watch
trailers let's not go out of your way to
watch trailers so this is the year where
i just
have largely stayed out of trailers i
thought it was about a guy palling
around with casper turns out
he dies down a manhole of all that what
a way to go
the point is he doesn't want to go great
beyond he's not ready and then he breaks
through and goes to this other place
which is the great before i believe they
call it which is where souls start out
and they get prepped to go to earth
very lds then he meets up with the soul
who's
the only soul smart enough to steer
clear of earth
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for
that is 22 knows what's up also that's
the best line in the movie
shocked they showed it in the trailers
like trailer showed that one so all
right now we have a journey of
self-discovery in which
two people are going to all the spirits
i suppose are going to help each other
find out about each other and a story
that goes straight to the
soul well that was a lot of setup for
one video but there's a lot to like
about this movie i mean first of all
jamie foxx plays the voice of joe tina
fey plays 22
i believe tina fey plays 22. yup all
right there you go
it's it sucks when you get information
wrong in a video because you're like
well that's permanent that's there now
but they did well together they worked
as a pair
i love the story of joe because joe's
character is the one that
asks the real question the entire time i
was like yeah
22 tina face character i agree
wholeheartedly
moving on to joe granted throughout the
movie 22 is going to get brainwashed
into being convinced that she's wrong
when she was completely right and
avoiding earth god what a downer this
video
i'm sorry i don't mean to be a downer
i'm just saying if you can hang out in
some cosmic wonderlands
you know given the choice of the two but
i really gravitated towards the story of
joe you know he's the guy who
wants his shot hasn't really gotten his
shot
he has enough regrets in life he wants
to have that shot like there are a lot
of
mature themes in this movie of the pixar
movies i can think of
this is probably the most mature that's
not to say you know sex drugs and rock
and roll or anything like that it's not
like that but in terms of the themes
it's dealing with it's just they're
themes that
in my experience kids don't really
contemplate
yet i mean they will eventually when
they're no longer kids when they're old
enough to be adults
who have possibly made the wrong
decisions or at least made decisions in
their life
that have provoked them years after the
fact to reflect
on their lives and wonder hey did i make
the right decision there you know you
have to be old enough to have made
monumental decisions in your life enough
to where you possibly have regrets
that's really the demographic of the
movie's soul
in which case that's probably its
greatest strength and maybe its biggest
weakness
more of a strength and a weakness for me
because i connected with that you know
because we all think about that stuff
there were a lot of takeaways i had in
this movie that made me think back to
actually a conversation i had with my
dad
a couple days ago we was talking my
dad's really talented
in music and electronics he made
electronics his career because that
paid the bills when he had he was
married and had kids but he was talking
about how
if he was given the choice he would have
stuck with
music more but if he had made his hobby
his career
would he have gotten sick of it because
at a point he kind of got burned out on
electronics but music is still his
passion to this day so would that be the
case if he had made
music his career i don't know but these
are the takeaways i had from
seoul and they're actually pretty
monumental for me i don't even know if
that's an intended takeaway
but it was for me so that's what matters
is actually a great
parable lesson monologue in here that
really put that into perspective
very well but again it's one of those
things that i don't think kids are
really gonna connect with it's good to
have so they have that lesson to reflect
back on but for the sake of this movie
they're probably gonna be like
i really dig the part where the person
and the cat are palling around
and it's a person cat buddy movie and
pixar's always had themes that hit with
adult and kids you know they're family
movies in the sense that parents can
take their kids to these movies
and not want to leave you know they're
not like i'm here for the kids
i hope they're having fun no adults can
lock in and be like wow i really like
that and i took away something from it
this might be the pixar movie where
adults are like oh wow
that's profound stuff and kids are like
i want to watch cartoons the deeper
themes in this movie might go over their
heads because they're just not
there yet i also like the bars where it
deals with people in that
trance state you know the state in
between states
basically the people you think are
hippie crazies it's like what if they've
just figured it out this being a disney
pixar movie
they could not have joe rogan on any
substances
in here but if it wasn't a disney pixar
movie
he would have been i promise in the end
i really dug soul i heard like you know
everyone cries at the end of this movie
i didn't cry which made me feel like a
hardened
horrid human folks look at my face
i'm just here now but it was a really
touching movie i really dug it it's a
touching character film
an irrelevant human film just in terms
of the philosophies
of life and how to live and how to see
your life your talents your calling in
life that's an important thing in a
world where the questions on such
matters seem to
grow exponentially the questions grow
the answers are fewer
and what to do this is a movie that
attempts to give you a good philosophy
to look at
i appreciate it and i was entertained
you know
if i could have both that's ideal but
it's another win for pixar what can i
say seoul's definitely worth watching
and worth
buying on blu-ray even though you can
watch it on disney plus
do i have to change that i don't know it
just seems like more of a firm answer
than
we're streaming on the service you
probably already have
alright so soul have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you